I so my name is Adam Miller I'm
moderating the panel today for talking
about open Jas there's been a whole lot
of work that has gone into this and this
couldn't this can just between be
between you and me we won't tell the
panelists but how many people have liked
know what I found a s foundations do and
how much work they put in and have like
interacted with them a lot and should
probably be up here on this panel okay I
see a few hands who knows that the
foundations or the foundations exist
and kind of know what they what they do
but really I couldn't couldn't give a
talk on it or be on the panel here now
okay and who's like wait we're talking
about foundations what we're talking
about we're talking I'll open source
right why is our foundation involved
okay cool well we have done a lot of
work we've done a lot of work recently
to merge together the node foundation
and the JavaScript foundation into the
open Jas foundation I it has been about
a ten month process or more i and we're
really excited to share with you what
we've been doing so there's an awesome
panel here of people who have been
absolutely rocking it on the the
foundation a formation side and yeah I
guess we'll go down the line and do do
intros here joy do you want to kick it
up yes hi my name is George Burton and I
was a member of the tack of the Jays
foundation which is now of course the
open Jays foundation and I work with the
Jays open Jays foundation now as sort of
a concierge to the projects and I work
with an organization called Oasis and
boku where I do a lot of standards work
I'm Michael Dawson line by Mia IBM's
community lead for nodejs that means I
get to spend a lot of time in the
node.js community I'm on the technical
steering committee and had the great
privilege to participate in a lot of the
work we did in putting together the
governance for the Open Jazz foundation
hi I'm Tracy Hines I wear a few hats
I work as head of platform at Samsung
next four day hours I also sit on
bored of open Jas Foundation and before
that worked on the node.js Foundation
and helped filled up the community
committee as a top-level committee and I
also run a nonprofit called gather
script which helps build more inclusive
web conferences stateside for now and
provide a financial umbrella for
community run conferences that don't
have that set up for themselves hi I'm
miles I'm a developer advocate for
Google cloud platform as of right now
I'm Google's board representative as a
platinum level board member and the vice
chair of the board of the open J's
Foundation prior to that during the
merger I was the TSEs elected
representative on the board in the
original structure of the node.js
foundation there were three board seats
that were for community members and
Tracy had wanted them and I was
representing the other group I've talked
enough
Adam awesome and like I said before I'm
Adam Miller and the current community
committee chairperson for node and in
the daytime I work at LinkedIn focused
on design systems and front-end built
systems so we can't really talk about
the future of the foundation without
kind of looking looking to the past and
I'd love to get just like a quick
synopsis TLDR on the node foundation and
the the JavaScript foundation
Jory do you want to kick it off give us
the brief description of what the jsf
yes sure so a lot of people may not
realize that the JavaScript community
has had a foundation working on behalf
of open-source projects for a long time
back in the mid-2000s we had the jquery
project that got wildly popular and we
created a foundation for jquery that
added projects over time it later merged
with what was the dojo foundation which
had a handful of projects itself and
kind of just that was about three years
ago four years ago and so that was when
we became the jas foundation and
we've been sort of rocking along and
sort of the behind-the-scenes for quite
some time and the Lucia's foundation was
formed in 2015 to provide a neutral
place where a number of different groups
within the the node community could come
together and work on figuring out how to
move things forward into the future
there is a few sort of you know key
things that were important which I think
we'll see flow through to what's what we
see in the open days foundation which
was you know strong technical
independence for the projects as well as
that neutrality where you know if
anybody comes in and participates and
contributes they can you know they have
all the tools and all the access that
they need to make things happen and
again I think that's something that
we'll see reflected in what we talked
about in the note open Jays foundation
as well and you know I think you know
from my perspective I think it's worked
really well it was the September of 2015
we reunited the four decks io j s and
the former Giants no streams and we've
seen like consistent and reliable
releases ever since then so I think it's
a good sign of the stability and the
ability for everybody to get in and work
together and on that front yeah and I
know early on when when it was just in
early discussions about the two
foundations merging there was a there's
a good bit of uncertainty about whether
it should it should happen whether this
was the right time to do it and I know a
lot of you feel that a lot of those
those concerns early on as I was hoping
you could answer maybe why now and why
merge can you repeat that one more time
really quickly why why are we merging
now and why I'm sorry the reason for the
merge it's been a long couple days so
there's a number of different reasons to
consider merging foundations if you go
and look at the bylaws of the foundation
itself right in there
we claim that we want to be a center of
gravity for the JavaScript ecosystem and
prior to there being one primary
foundation the it wasn't really clear
[Music]
it's hard because node was the main
project in the node.js foundation and
joining something bigger means giving
some stuff up and there's an anecdote
that I really liked when I kind of
started getting into the node.js
ecosystem when I had just moved to
California I I got Dee Shaw got me a
free ticket to go to a conference called
notes summit and this was right around
the time of the fork and they were
talking about merging and I have no
shame so I walked right up to Scott
Hammond at the time the CEO of giant and
asked him why would you put note in a
foundation and he had a great answer
which was it's much better to have a
smaller piece of a bigger pie and to me
when I think about these foundations and
we just had our summit recently which
was fantastic and so many new faces in
the room that weren't there before we
just massively expanded the scope of the
work that we can do who we can work with
how we can work with them we get to
revisit all of these kind of
preconceived notions when note first one
in the foundation it was very reactive
we had things we needed to protect and
fix but now we can be really proactive
and we can start thinking about what we
want to build yeah I'll just throw in
two senses like it just made me think we
all know that we can accomplish a lot
more than we could on our own as an
individual so it's kind of the same
thing for a larger foundation and sort
of wearing the node hat there was a lot
of skepticism when we were talking about
a merger and and not uh I wouldn't
necessarily say it was very balanced
there's a lot from the node side and
again it was because we had experience
going through I think a pretty
tumultuous foundation formation not too
many years ago and node was finally
feeling like a stable place sort of
firing on all cylinders we were working
together in the community and the TSC
but I think as part of that we ended up
seeing how bringing in the upstream
components in the jas ecosystem that
like we we were stronger when we
we're doing that together and so by
focusing on these sorts of things that
we had already learned transparency
including not just including giving
autonomy to the project members so that
they could run and host these meetings
we ran weekly meetings when it came to
the merger discussions and planning so
that whoever wanted to drive the
planning from particular initiative
phases of making this merger happen it
was only gonna happen if people showed
up and did the work and that was from
the project side not from the board side
yeah I'll just add that on the the Jays
foundation side like we immediately saw
the the benefit of possibly like merging
with the node ecosystem because all of
our projects really rely on node at the
same time there was some like you know
fear and uncertainty because there was a
lot of historical drama and and you know
energy from the community that may be
disruptive to what was otherwise fairly
stable projects and so you know with
that sort of you know optimism but but
cautious optimism in mind everybody got
really excited about the possibility of
collaborating more closely with their
peers on the node side through one
umbrella and I think that's kind of what
put us over the edge and one of the
things that you know building on what
what both Traci and Roy was saying front
from the get-go we approached this front
from Anna Galit arian mindset we made
the doors open like we tried to be hyper
inclusive as much as possible if you
were a member or committer and like even
then we weren't really that picky like
basically if you wanted to show up to
those meetings and you weren't being
disruptive you had a voice and a seat at
the table and were participating and I
think that that was really important to
make sure that this could be successful
there's I was just going to say we
looked at the governance for a number of
the different projects of the node
project the jsf aound ation kubernetes
and i'm really happy that we actually I
think ended up with something which is
probably the most open and has the most
opportunity and I'm hopefully
you know the best place where people
will want to come and and will attract a
lot of good people through that so I'm
really happy that you know by looking at
that we ended up with that open and
really nice governance and I think that
the and all of the scribes home that the
value of this work is always project
driven and that's the point of the
foundation is to help empower and give
autonomy to the projects and get sort of
the the crap out of the way for them to
be able to do their good work yeah I
think what I've heard on that front is
we talk about great projects and the
focus will be on those great projects
not the foundation itself
yeah so let's dig into some of that
nitty-gritty I mean almost everybody in
the room here is an engineer and I've
always held the opinion that that
governance is just coding but with words
I it's really what it's felt like over
the past 10 months and we actually have
a bit of a visual aid here as we talk
about it but let's dive into some more
nitty-gritty details here under the
under the hood of what's kind of making
this foundation new foundation tick and
we can talk about on the back story and
and reasoning behind these these
sections of the foundation I yeah so I
mean let's take it from the from the top
we'll go like open open Jas board let's
talk about their functionality and we'll
work our way down yeah so just to start
out with you know and I talked a little
bit about the governance we end up
having multiple levels so they're
observers anybody who's who wants to can
come up and actually participate in the
meetings we want to get as many
different ideas to come to the best
answers we then have regular members who
can actually your people are in my mind
who've said I'm making a commitment to
be involved regularly and they can be
recognized for that and again you know
both observers and regular members are
are involved in all of the work that
goes on and then finally we have voting
members where in the rare cases where we
need to actually have a vote on
something it's that subset who will who
will do that vote now our experience in
the node project at least has been that
votes are very rare you know we follow a
consensus seeking approach and so really
it's going to be
all of those members who have ownership
and who push things forward and so it
shouldn't really matter which level
you're in but you know we have to just
have the different levels for the
contingencies one thing that I can add a
mantra Iowa Tom myself was that we
wanted to create structures and
hierarchies of responsibilities rather
than power so there isn't fundamentally
a major power balance between any of the
members of any other projects being a
voting member just means you're more
responsible you need to be showing up
you need to be making sure that things
are getting finished but you don't get
to just shut down another person's voice
because you have that responsibility
yeah the governance is really written so
that all the responsibilities that the
CPC are the responsibilities of all the
members as opposed to anybody in
particular I want to talk a little bit
about the projects if we can the staging
because I think for me this was a big
bringing all these j/s foundation
projects and board it was really
important to me that they felt that they
had a voice in the process and they
could really see themselves and and
where they were gonna drive value and
get services and that sort of thing from
the organization so we came up with this
proposal that was loosely based on the
CN CF model of impact projects growth
stage projects at large projects and
what's not pictured here are Emeritus
projects which we have six projects that
we sort of deemed and the project's
themselves opted into this stage
functionally complete we recognize and
thank them for the contributions they
made to the community but we're not
really encouraging people to go
contribute to those projects or adopt
those projects now but so we have six
impact or five impact projects which are
sort of the projects that are a real
kind of need to have some resources and
support on a very active basis from the
foundation
they're used heavily and enterprise and
they need that backing we have six
growth projects and that stage is for
projects that have a specific objective
in mind like there is a goal I need I
want to grow my contributor base I want
to increase the number of
implementations I want to put on an
event or something like that they have
some specific goal for which they need
extra resources from the foundation for
a short period of time growth stages for
those projects and then we have 15 at
large projects which are projects that
don't really they're they're fine
they're kind of doing their thing their
resource needs are pretty set and we
don't have to do too much to support
that one thing I can add from the at
large show the node.js foundation I had
kind of said will node was the only
project that was kind of half true
node had at one point attempted an
incubation program to bring more
projects in and it the Express project
and the libuv project were two of those
projects that came in to the node.js
Foundation I personally and I can't
speak for how other people feel I don't
feel that that program was very
successful but while we were emerging
you know we have to make sure all
projects are accounted for and both
libuv and Express primarily wanted to
just continue operating the way that
they were to be able to not have
anything day-to-day change and perhaps
have a bit of a better idea of what
resources were available to them such as
CI or legal counsel or PR and marketing
in case they needed it but they mostly
just didn't want anything to change and
by coming in as an at-large project
these two projects which were mostly on
Rails doing their own thing as far as I
know and I'm saying this because we just
haven't heard anything from them like it
seems like everything's going fine and
there's been pretty much no change day
to day and so to me I see a lot of these
projects as you do your thing the way
you want to do your thing and we're here
to support you when you need it and one
of the really big things I think we'll
want to be doing in the near future is
codifying and making it far clearer or
what resources are available how to get
access to those resources
and how to create programs for new
resources if they're not available yet I
think we're much better set up now to to
deal with and cope with the different
thing that the different requirements
are different aspirations that each
project will have as opposed to you know
being part of the node.js Foundation
where you really you know a small part
of a bigger project do I want to talk a
little bit about the the membership
structure and and how the how
representation works at the the layer
above the CPC I sorry you just repeat
that do you want to talk about I'd love
to hear a bit about the membership
structure and and the layer and how the
CPC interacts with the rest of the org a
little bit I think Adam just let me know
if you're wrong you're asking about like
how is the CPC formed and what's the
structure of the foundation yeah on the
community side I'll start one thing that
is really important and this is the only
thing I really wanted to say is that the
board which you're seeing over on the
left-hand side which is made up of a
number of different members from
corporate entities as well as three team
up to three community members right now
it is three it will go down to two soon
there's governance bylaws grab me I'll
explain but that that group is
responsible for the things that you see
listed there they do not have authority
over anything else the rest of the
day-to-day operations of the foundation
that you see under the cross project
Council as well as the day-to-day
technical governance of projects is
completely air-gapped now the board and
projects can work together on things it
doesn't mean that we are not partners
but what it does mean is that the
foundation could not install people into
a project I think a good example here
that I can provide is what happens if a
code of conduct violation happens with
someone on leadership in one of the
projects what would hope that a project
would be able to manage that conflict
themselves and resolve it it's really
hard
to have to enforce those policies on
someone that you've worked with for
years that you've seen work really hard
but that you're seeing disagreements on
so you know by experience we've seen
this sort of happen that you could end
up having it saying like okay board we
need you to provide an answer because we
don't really know what to do here and we
know you have experience in it and the
board instead of saying okay we you know
you're gonna do this thing
it's instead saying we're gonna help you
provide resources and we're gonna work
with you together to figure this out but
ultimately you're responsible for this
work we just want to be here to guide
you and provide the monetary resources
the legal resources to help resolve that
together and hopefully we'll be better
for that in the long run I could say so
so taking on from the the the board
participation we then have voting
members which are elected we have two
from each of the impact project so and
it's up to the project to decide how
they want to elect those representatives
we also have to which represent all of
the the non impact projects although
this year for as a bootstrap we accept
that everybody who wanted to participate
at that level into the the CPC which i
think is really great because we want to
kick off with as many people as we can
involved in helping to move things
forward and then we actually can have an
additional two voting members who are
elected from the regular members so if
we see some people who haven't been
elected by an individual project but are
doing a lot of work and really helping
to move the CPC work forward they can
actually be you know elected as voting
members as well thank you well they were
coming up on time here off stage at some
point so I just want to go rapid fire
starting with miles what are you what if
they're if people leave here with one
takeaway from from this panel what would
you what would you like it to be you
don't have to do this alone
yeah so I think I'm really excited to
see how we're gonna be able to like cut
again as miles and we've said this
excitement from the summit this week
prior to Jas copy you it was awesome to
get to see all of these folks stepping
up from the JSE Co system saying like
we're excited we didn't know that
there's a possibility here
so getting able to do things like take
the work that we've done an ode and get
to talk to people in other groups in the
ecosystem or in the projects currently
now in the foundation to get to work
together on these things it's exciting
to see the opportunity that we have now
in JavaScript to be able to work
together on this stuff even from helping
more on the standard side yeah for me
it's all about new opportunities and
that I see a lot more opportunities for
us to collaborate together to have a
greater impact across projects and to
achieve you know bigger things we have
an opportunity to achieve things we
wouldn't have been able to achieve on
our own so it's about operat new
opportunities across all the different
aspects I have like 37 things I'd like
to share with people but bearing in mind
that we have like a minute and a half
left and I think the the first thing
that I'd like to take away for y'all to
take away is that there's a lot of
opportunity for you to give impact and
what services the open Jas foundation
provides to your projects and you can do
that by following along with our work on
the open J's Foundation github
organization the bootstrap oh it's
actually called the C cross project
Council repo now and if you have an idea
for something that would be helpful to
you as a member of one of our projects
or as a potential member of one of our
projects like please write a proposal or
open an issue on that and start
following along with our meetings and
that sort of thing on on YouTube and
our weekly meetings there we have a
great new email list you can start to
receive these weekly emails from us that
sort of summarizes like what's going on
we have a J's foundation slack channel
which I'll change over to the open JSL
select channel eventually so there's a
lot of opportunities to start having
these conversations together and you can
make a difference you can you know come
and I can't wait to see you they're
wonderful and I just want to say I saw a
lot of this this collaboration between
projects starting at the the most recent
collaborator summit which was actually
right before this conference we got
people from across the new open J's
foundation together it was historically
just a note event but the conversations
that actually happened in the hallway
and in talks are things that I could
only dream about you know we build
amazing things on the internet together
we build amazing things with JavaScript
together and like miles put it we don't
have to do it alone and we do it better
together so definitely go and get
involved we are up on github you can go
to the website thank you all for coming
to this panel
[Applause]
[Music]